one of the things that I um I took away
from your first book happy sexy
millionaire we can talk about the title
of that
um but one of the things I really took
away was the quitting framework yeah um
I wonder if you can talk through that
for people who might not have come
across I feel like you know better than
me but I'll but I'll but I'll pop at it
so the reason I wrote the quitting
framework is because I realized in
hindsight that I was able to quit things
easier than most people let's take one
step back why is quitting important in
life we glamorize starting right but my
observation was that the advantage I've
had as I've said was being able to quit
fast and eat with peace and ease and
when you just think logically about
starting something right or saying it's
also the same with like saying yes and
no to things
in order to start something in life you
actually
first need to quit something else so you
can't start a new relationship unless
you quit the last one you're not going
to start a new startup unless you've
quit the last one
um you're not going to start a new
career career unless you've quit the
last job so quitting and starting should
be held in equal regard and there should
be acknowledgment that they have a
two-way relationship with one another
they're both the actions of winners
people say quitting is for losers and
they say like starting is for winners in
fact quitting and starting are both for
winners they're in the the most
successful intelligent people I've ever
met have an unbelievable ability to quit
things that make no objective sense
you're quitting that high-paying job to
go and deal to go and do card tricks at
a table in Bristol Darren Brown you're
quitting that amazing career as a lawyer
um that your parents are now so proud of
you of to go and spend the next 10 years
going up and down the country in pubs
and cracking jokes Jimmy Carr it just
objectively seems to make no sense but
subjectively they've reached a certain
level of ease so I I could relate to
myself in the same way in the regard of
if you look at what I've quit from like
stop going to school because I realized
that that wasn't going to gonna be the
paper that I got at the end of the
process wasn't going to be enough
especially compared to my brothers quit
University after that first lecture quit
my first startup after two years quit my
second one after about six years
um and lots of little quitting in
amongst there
um why was I able to quit with with
peace Ins at times when objectively you
would think I was a Madman for doing so
when I was leaving so much apparently on
the table
and so I tried to make a framework a
framework that other people could use to
try and make their quitting decisions
through so at the start of the framework
you ask yourself am I thinking of
quitting it's either you know yes or no
so if you are thinking of quitting the
framework begins and I created these two
subcategories
which you can Define for yourself which
I think is important to do you're either
thinking of quitting something because
it's something's really hard like it's
difficult
and then which would be you know you're
running a marathon and you're on the
23rd Mile and you're doing it you know
to raise money for a charity but it's
really it's painful it's difficult it's
it's causing discomfort or you're
thinking about quitting something
because it like it sucks and that's more
of like an emotional mental thing it's
just it just doesn't feel good to you on
an emotional mental psychological level
so let's go down the hard route I'm
thinking of quitting because it's hard
the first question you should then ask
yourself is
is the hardship worth the rewards on
offer so you're running that Marathon
you're raising money for that leukemia
charity you're on the 23rd mile but it's
worth it the the hardship is worth the
reward at the end of it if the hardship
is worth it don't quit if the hardship
isn't worth it
then you should quit because the worst
thing to do in life is to do something
that is hard and meaningless like those
are those are where all the problems
happen when I think about studies of
the impact of not having autonomy in
your work and working on a production
line and not having meaning and purpose
in what you're doing every day and how
that impacts your health and disease
rises in your body that is the worst
situation to be in let's go down the
other side of the framework
by the way do correct me because you
know this framework by the time
hey we'll get on the other side of the
framework so you're thinking about
quitting something because it sucks
you're in a relationship your husband
you know the the magic has just left the
relationship you're in a company and
there's problems at work but you you
know you haven't yet had the
conversation with your boss the next
question becomes
do you believe you could make it not
suck
right so in the context of a marriage
um that might mean going to marriage
counseling and having a difficult
conversation thrashing it out with your
partner and you know going through those
issues if the answer is no it so it
sucks you think you can't change that
quit if you believe you could make it
nuts not suck the next question to ask
yourself is
is the effort that it would take to make
it not suck worth the rewards on offer
so like you look at how that marriage
might look if you were to resolve it you
believe you can is it worth it is Dave
worth it is the is the reward on the
other end of that process to fix it
sucking worth it
if the answer is no quit you believe you
could make it nuts not not suck anymore
but the effort it would take is not
worth the reward on offer quit if you
believe you could make it not suck and
the effort it would take is worth the
rewards on offer stay and fight for it
and that's my simple framework which is
intentionally ambiguous
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye